well
[Music]
how are you Cristian cásseres greets you with
his brief news now in
Spanish a fire consumed a complex
of residences under construction shortly
before midnight the images of the
incident are impressive as you can
see everything happened between the tropicana and
fort apache  and several surrounding residents have
been evacuated
now the 206 unit complex has been
completely destroyed as well as
several construction crews so
far no one was injured more than
100 las vegas' clark county firefighters
henderson and our begues
worked together to put out the flames
now the southern nevada health district
is planning appointments for
frontline workers as part
of the plan to vaccinate the population
against coronavirus under the new
category more people are now
eligible to receive the vaccine
these include teacher
bank workers  of food and drivers of
public transport and  he plan is to open more
vaccination centers like fiesta and
engineers at ali and jane stadium which
are some landmarks
and the governor sticks that will give his
annual speech tonight where he will reveal
his vision to grow the state of
nevada it is estimated that  mentioning the
force that stood out in the community
during the pandemic news now will broadcast
the speech starting at
6pm and also the response from
the republican party afterwards and the
strong winds were felt
throughout the night reaching almost 30 miles
per hour in various parts of the valley a
slight system will be passing by
us for the next few hours and
that can cause light rain for
us and even snowflakes in the
mountains the temperature will rise to 50
degrees and increase for tomorrow
is expected  rain and snow for the
mountains for this weekend I am
cristian cásseres and this is your brief
informative of Spanish ignition happy
tuesday
[M  music]